come to hannity all right tonight we are
tracking multiple very big
breaking developing stories coming up
we'll bring you the new details
surrounding the lincoln project scandal
this story keeps getting worse and worse
by the day
a smoking gun email just the news.com as
just revealed
showing james comey new hillary
clinton's dirty
russian disinformation dossier was
unverified yet he signed
three fisa applications two now we are
certainly signed while knowing that it's
not verifiable
john durham calling john durham where
are you
also tonight new york governor cuomo is
now facing widespread condemnation
from both sides of the aisle but will he
be held responsible
for his covet nursing home death
cover-up we have a full report straight
ahead
and also later we'll have the very
latest rundown of the biden
administration's radical far left agenda
yep
including now they're coming for your
second amendment
as we warned you now donald trump jr
will be joining us tonight dan bongino
will be here but first
this weekend and what could be well the
least shocking development we told you
all last week it was predetermined the
outcome
the former president donald trump was
officially acquitted take a look
senate having tried donald john trump
former president united states upon one
article of impeachment
exhibited against him by the house
representatives
and two-thirds of the senators present
not having found him guilty of the
charge
contained therein it is therefore
ordered
and a judge that they said donald john
trump be
and he is hereby acquitted of the charge
in said article let's make one thing
clear the seven republican senators have
voted to convict
donald trump and other republicans who
have turned their backs on the former
president
are way out of touch with the base of
their own party record 75 million
americans turned out
for donald trump in november and they
support him to this very day
take a look right there see that video
see what's on your screen
a few hours ago spontaneously
thousands of people in palm beach
lined up in support of the former
president as his motorcade
traveled through florida i have a
question mitch mcconnell
john thune how come you never had this
kind of enthusiasm at
any of your events take a look
[Applause]
usa
[Applause]
[Music]
voters of this country are smart they're
not stupid they can see the snap
impeachment was nothing but political
theater no due process no evidence no
defense
none of it and now we're finding out
that oh it was all pre-planned ahead of
time
and another needless smear that
accomplished nothing
it's been five years of this they've
also had it with republicans
and democratic swamp creatures
and this is a question the republicans
are now going to have to ask themselves
tonight
where was john thune and mitch mcconnell
fighting against the biggest abuse of
power corruption
scandal in our history with operation
crossfire hurricane they were missing in
action
where is the sanctimony as mitch
mcconnell john thune demanding that
kamala harris chuck schumer nancy pelosi
maxine waters
when is he going to give a speech on the
senate floor
and hold those democrats accountable for
their
incitement of insurrection and their
insurrection-like language the time is
now coming
for new leadership in the u.s senate
we'll be dealing with that
we'll have a lot more in the days to
come there is important work though that
does need to be done it's urgent
now this was all put on hold because of
this political
latest show trial in this case first and
foremost what happened on the 6th
of january can never happen again our
capital was attacked
elected lawmakers both parties were put
in harm's way
that can't ever happen again all those
that broke the law must be held
responsible
and we need a full investigation into
what went wrong the security was
breached within minutes
the capitol police were overwhelmed
prior to the breach the capitol police
chief
requested the national guard and their
assistance
six separate times every plea of his
was rejected the president was very
vocal about offering
his security assistance leading up to
january 6 and even ordered 10 thousand
national guard troops to be on standby
and be ready
but they were not called on until it was
too late
why did this happen now they knew a
massive crowd of hundreds of thousands
of people they knew
days before they were descending on
washington they knew the night before
they were there
they knew this was an important day in
the halls of congress
they knew the vice president and all our
elected officials would be inside the
capitol building
they knew that violent individuals we
now know
were plotting and planning and scheming
they were warned the fbi knew about the
plots the planning the scheming
as did other law enforcement agencies
even congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez
claimed she was warned about the attack
a week ahead of time
the person ultimately responsible for
security
in the house that would be nancy pelosi
the sergeant of arms
answers to her but instead of getting to
the bottom of this massive security
failure
well no the speaker just rushed through
yet another snap impeachment
no due process no presumption of
innocence no defense
having no facts and no investigation and
recently she didn't even want to answer
questions about this
massive post-9 11 security failure
she called it a waste of time take a
look
as far as the impeachment trial is
concerned
senator graham said that if the
democrats call
any witness that they'll be prepared the
republicans will be prepared to call in
the fbi
and quote tell us about people who
pre-planned this attack and what
happened
with the security footprint at the
capitol what's your response to that
your question is a waste of time
protecting our institutions and
protecting
uh elected officials from both sides of
the aisle is not a waste of time
and now that the impeachment charade is
over having never investigated a thing
pelosi is now finally ordering a
full-scale investigation
i'm sure it will focus only on donald
trump the reason for the delay
is obvious pelosi knew any serious
investigation
would clear president trump in fact
there is a mountain of evidence
that all of this was pre-planned and
that multiple
serious warnings were missed or ignored
it can't happen clearly january 6
those remarks could not have incited
insurrection
if the attack was organized well before
january 6 which we now know from court
documents the fbi
and so many others it was and so that by
the way the political
uh shift show charade is out of the way
pelosi can finally get on with the
business
of protecting every elected official and
our house the people's house make no
mistake
this is swamp sewer politics at its
worst but
what else would you expect from
democrats and nancy pelosi
and yeah even republicans like mitch
mcconnell and others
meanwhile this failed snap impeachment
also sets
a dangerous new precedent donald trump
can be impeached for political speech
where he urged supporters to fight like
hell
there's a 10-minute montage during the
trial david shone will join us later he
people he aired it for all of us to see
and that they would many of you will
now peacefully and patriotically march
to the capitol so your voices will be
heard
as senator lindsey graham explained now
pandora's box
has been wide open let's see if
republicans
will hold democrats to the new standard
take a look
we've opened pandora's box to future
presidents and if you use this model i
don't know how kamala harris
doesn't get impeached if the republicans
take over the house
because she actually bailed out rioters
and one of the writers went back to the
streets and broke somebody's head open
so we've opened pandora's box here and
i'm sad for the country
so it was mcconnell john thune others
are they now
going to use the same standard that was
used against donald trump
on inciting insurrection because there's
a long and growing list of democrats
who should now qualify for impeachment
and impeachment trial
he can start with kamala harris chuck
schumer joe biden and work your way
through the list
but of course swamp creatures the media
mob they'll likely never hold democrats
to the same standard that they held
donald trump to
that is pretty much the history of the
last five years
last week they were too busy
breathlessly cheering on
house impeachment managers and it was
all nauseating
and nobody in this country is better off
because of it
meanwhile the media had no shortage of
complaints about the president's legal
team
and they delivered an epic beat down
with an excellent defense
that was put together oh in about eight
days
over the weekend one of the president's
attorneys actually
dealing with a cbs anchor voiced his
frustration with the mob
during an interview on that network take
a look
the media has to start telling the right
story
in this country the media is trying to
divide this country
you are blood thirsty for ratings and as
such
you're asking questions now that are
already
uh set up with a fact pattern that's the
problem the media has to start living
by the truth and not trying to create a
narrative
michael van der veen yeah thank you for
joining us i
i do appreciate yeah okay all right
i see you taking off your microphone now
yeah he did
uh imagine having almost every news
outlet in the country rooning against
you every tv show every article
every headline every pundit every second
every minute every hour of every day
that's what this country's lived through
donald trump and his family have lived
through the last five years
and by the way that is what the
president's lawyers faced over the past
few weeks
and this is what president trump again
faced for five years journalism
in this country is dead and buried we
are in the middle
of an information crisis in this country
and
media is not coming back to life anytime
soon